so guys we've been given our first
official look at the soccer live action
TV series and Ahsoka is looking
absolutely fantastic even better than
what she looks like in the Mandalorian
series because the one big change that
they made is that their main her leku
her headpieces longer more accurate to
her character because in demand Lauren
her lekus were shorter for stunt reasons
and it wasn't accurate to her character
but it looks like they've gone ahead
come up with a solution and have changed
it and I gotta say it just looks so much
better and I know a lot of fans are
going to be happy with this change in
the next image we have the rebels mural
that we saw the end of rebels so here we
have our first look of Sabine here
fortunately we don't get the best look
at Sabine here but they've done a really
good job at transforming this Rebels
mural into the live action and this is a
show I just feel like they're going to
pour a lot of love into especially Dave
filoni because Rebels was his baby so he
probably wouldn't oversee this and make
sure everything is perfect now Rosario
Dawson the actress who plays a circus
said watching the first episode of a
circus series was of religious
experience so it looks like Davis
definitely works on Magicka now in the
next imagery there's not too much to
break down looks like Ahsoka is in some
ruins here a tomb or just a cave perhaps
whatever it is it is underground as the
light is shining on her from above
possibly she is searching for something
or she is doing meditation anyway that's
about it for this video guys let me know
what you think of these images in the
comments section below and are you
excited for the circus series and if you
haven't already please do consider
subscribing thanks for watching guys